Rebecca Harris time all my reading
dropped a little bits from last night's
okay we've played this so many times
before for those who don't know Rebecca
Harris is Geum nari did Sookie who is in
the chats recently okay I'm down the
bishop pair Ivan night always playoff
six there's this move let's play a five
and Bishop e7 coming maybe ninety four
nice night c5 is looks nice and I have
some office of Clare Bishop ending what
does G for let's just do nothing
hey for maybe I take that probably not
so there's like one trick in the
position oh that's kind of annoying take
sticks played way too slowly
[Music]
I'm just losing b5 maybe no
oh that's good move I was late
breakthrough that's how he breaks - king
of seven please I've flagged I was
holding my no kind of house rough does
the smooth g5 coming maybe okay we have
some weird London that's five yeah okay
this looks playable Wow
was a g4o leave the tension for now
little bit problematic here
just a little bit free pawn Oh free pawn
bishop takes a three
while takes lose this going on bishop
bath for maybe should have for
threatening this ah you saw it
wait maybe that's not so bad
oh no it is so bad it's very that to be
aggressive with my king
okay that's an arc oh yeah this is rough
let's take this okay have some position
I think at this point my goal isn't to
not get adopted
I'm just getting needed here that's not
fair it's really not fair I could take
somewhere maybe ooh
what's a move eh one's very strong okay
I'm gonna play on because I've hoped
lots of hope
okay hope is running low or is it okay
hope for an out I've lost three only
three though
some idea of pushing maybe I should hold
off okay seven is fancy healthy doesn't
do anything though Queen b6 coming or
not
wanna play Knight c4 that's just a free
pawn no it's not nothing in life is free
d6 is free though weird position let's
try and trade Queens Knights gonna have
to move or that move take sticks okay
we'll go for this endgame I can't take
before yet now I can
ah this is bad
thanks for the sub yeah me something oh
this is really bad
no this is actually really bad
I was trying the rosin trap it didn't
work though Oh yummy skink thanks for
subbing okay
playing some line it's not getting me
did I should beat your floor looks
interesting finding Bishop g4 now ship
g4 looks nice he opens a piece what is
this a queen sac
he wants to me me on each six so let's
not get made it
Bishop g5 and maybe f6 okay kind of solo
check the night outs it's gonna play 97
probably trying to kick it away like
soccer I take that I'll spy Bishop c1
first oh go away
hmm c5 I just want to trade let me trade
perché for random square stopped taking
stuff can trade some stuff don't meet me
please oh me me no I was so sad that was
so sad I was doing so well
until I lost on time lost all my pieces
okay let's play this stuff
what does this move get Center for trick
very tricky g4 incoming what does that
move c3 playable ephors hanging - do I
dare play b4 to try and counter attack
counter-attack 25 counter-attack
hmm okay counterplay is rampant let's
take this in each five
I'm just so slow every game it's not
good I like my chances here g5 I take
it's increased pressure first now g5
what does this move Bishop g7 feein
Kettering and blacks territory Queen B
Yeats what a move
no work g1 meant to be played the Queen
h8 is a threat now I see it having a
party on the back rank does this move no
I'm so slow ah I was up a rock in the
final position six games oh that's not
gonna adopted g3 coming I knew it let's
take that
d6 looks playable 94 ideas oh okay
this is fine I think IG for I take what
do I take let's take this then f6 solve
it let's take this a few times allowing
wait to go in draw draw new drama here
we go
let's go trade Queens yes plenty of time
I'm so fast
where's the king so slippery area okay I
want a game a game it's a miracle true
miracle play Queen no do I play here
maybe this line I know f5 oh it's a sub
cash making cashew thank you
how's it going okay I haven't seen cash
make you since PCL I play f5 here I'm so
slow this game how am I so slow oh okay
I'm still alive that I'll kind of don't
hurt me don't hurt me
oh that hurts okay I have to go for the
attack have to hurt him back how do i
attack that's a good move let's play
this move hmm wait am i winning no I'm
not winning or am I am i winning king h1
ah I'm not winning three seconds of 39
seconds I was rough
not the prettiest suppositions free
bishop thank you oh that's not free
because nothing in life is free weights
can I do this I can do that
not sure what's going on here it's a
weird position well what does this move
I'm down the exchange somehow I'm gonna
play this move I'm losing more material
never give up hope
except when it's too late okay those are
rough wait
Goldust Tori no you cannot root for
Daniels you might get banned for that
there's no rooting for Tania in the chat
what does this move this is okay it
stick here for okay I like this position
oh let's play rook on h4 f5 is
interesting wow so brave it's bits
yeah but I'm slow relative to his
ridiculous speed it's sad it's mildly
infuriating played this move I want to
take enough 7 or trot the night and the
night strapped yes I'm so slow I'm down
a lot of time and it might actually
trapped its counter-attacking let's take
your first that was a bad life decision
now I'm actually down material put my
down material you have to go for a
counter play moved for the king
[Music]
stop it okay we'll trade some snow it's
a fork oh okay I have to speed up in the
opening I think he's gonna play that
okay let's play this oh no I already
mess up maybe it's okay so weird opening
fork oh that's not gonna end well okay
let's give some stuff here g6 play rugby
5 I wanna play a 5 ok well I could have
one F pot shall win this pond and then
this kills defend this one let's start
pushing H pawn only down 10 seconds g5
get some g5 emotes well let's not get
made
what's going on I don't have any checks
and I'm gonna get me that life's not
fair
life is really not fair
maybe I'll do some tricky move please
play Queen c7 okay I'm not a doctor yet
it's ten to something to one it's not a
freak on maybe of this you take ooh
there's gonna be Connor play play off
for a fight was probably questionable
but I kind of like my position g5
incoming g5 oh you want some maybe I'm
safe though I think I'm safe
what is this position
oh I'm not safe no why why why
oh I thought I was safe let's play the
slain free pop was a g4 o g4 is a move s
98 defending that six could be
questionable I'm trying to provoke him
to sac sac he does let's play this move
I think I'm alive ah
so I lose material but now I have
counterplay know why I'm training Queens
let's defend that who frees stuff like
free stuff ah no no in the spawn I mean
that's fun too Oh No
[Music]
what's going on here thanks for tricky
no no I lost oh oh my Knights weren't
tricky enough cuz I lost one of them
[Music]
okay I'm doing stuff in this game which
should not be tried at home
I lost a pond but I have a dark Street
Bishop was this move that's interesting
let's defend hmm can open the C file
a little bit uncomfortable
you have to use my king king power oh oh
that's not what I was expecting to
happen okay that's a fork I'm losing
stuff though take this thing I'm too
slow I'm too slow okay thanks for the
bits Smith more I could try try that if
you play Sicilian maybe I will
yeah that's not supposed to be dubious
is this what is this my castle it's a
legal move castling okay I'm not getting
made it I don't think unless I am takes
let's play this first will you what does
this move this is okay
ah that's a Charla oh no it's solve lost
No what does the oppa Gangnam style oh
let's play Smith Maura or not the alkyne
okay
King FA it was a mouse slip I take that
okay this looks reasonable just have to
win this pawn maybe not there pawn too
nap on
loses
don't want to be second-guessing myself
g5 is so close to mates so close to mate
I'm threading meat into know I needed
that thing ah
let's check how's that check was rough
20 games one two three four five six
seven eight nine no I can't get adopted
this is game nine I'll game ten
there we go okay when the rook that's
why I needed no adoption for you oh
shoot
type blonde or something may have
blundered something what's going on here
I think I'm alive though
pretty sure I'm alive somehow finding
safety this night strapped
I mean I'm up a rook Knights still
trapped we have three expected
okay untangling
a lot of material a little bit of
pressure still now I have counterplay I
can take on each six no wait